this is a slideshow of the data science
at nlm training course
title text data science at nlm logo
the data science at nlm training course
classroom a male student working
on his laptop the male instructor at the
front of the class
side by side shots one facing class and
one facing the projector screen
students on their laptops profile of a
female student watching the instructor
a male and female student on their
laptops
close-up profile of a female student
typing two female students and a male
student in the back row this shot slides
over to share screen with shot of male
student getting help from male
instructor
male instructor pointing at information
on the projector screen this shares a
screen with a profile of students in the
front row
two male students in the middle row
close up of a man with a laptop
smiling at the camera back to title text
data science at nlm logo